community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
one of the many ways we can measure
things getting kind of back to normal is
the return of live performances
including local theater a public fit
theater company is back in action and
here to tell us more about that we have
our good friend tyler quarter from
findlay automotive group the sponsors of
this segment along with anne marie
pereth from a public theater company
thank you both for being here today
thank you great to be here tyler why is
this important to get behind something
like this so we we just love supporting
live theater community theater we think
it's good for this the community and and
uh you know the arts and all that sort
of thing so we've sponsored them uh
pre-pandemic we sponsored a couple of
productions we we sponsored wit and we
sponsored uh the elephant man and so we
just love those uh those performances so
now that we're kind of coming out of the
pandemic the live theater is back again
we're sponsoring some upcoming
productions uh at the public fit theater
company so that's why i want to bring
anne marie on talk a little bit about
what they got going on over there i
really appreciate that yeah and you are
the director of the upcoming yes i'm
co-directing it with uh joseph coopkin
and the show that we're working on is
things i know to be true and it's an
australian playwright
and it has
two parents and four children and it's
about a family who has conflict who has
dysfunction but they love each other
incredibly and they're able to weather a
lot of storms and this is going on in
april and if people haven't been to it's
called the usual place yes it's a
smaller theater so it's a great venue to
see these kind of things yeah it seats
about 60 to 80 depending on how we set
up the house because it's a black box
theater and what i like about small
venues is that the audience is very
close to the story it's like a fishbowl
experience they can really peer into the
story it's almost immersive so they
really feel involved in the story and
what i love about bringing audiences
into the venue is uh in this particular
case there are six characters the
audience actually plays as the seventh
character
because depending on if you have an
introverted audience or an extroverted
audience they can re really feed into
that experience for the actors on stage
and the audience in the house and the
actors themselves are they all las vegas
based
uh in this particular production yes we
use all professional uh performers but
in the past like he mentioned elephant
man we brought in somebody from new york
but we do try and hire professionals we
pay all of our our staff all of uh the
production team the designers and the
actors yeah it's first rate yes yeah the
designs themselves are a big deal you
bring in some really good designs yeah
we bring in uh like our to the lighting
designers from chicago our scenic
designer is from texas and we we put
together a
design team so that we can really create
a cohesive world that really informs the
story yeah emery thank you so much and
tyler thank you for all you do in the
community and including supporting there
you go thank you it's great being here
all right thank you
so you can uh
check out the play by going here
public fit theater company and the uh
website is a public fit.org the show is
running april 1st to the 25th at the
usual place theater and you can also
call a phone number not on the screen
we'll have it attached to our website so
you can get those tickets